hi my name is penny adler and i am a
soap artisan on the 444 farm where we
have goats that we use to make in our
soap and i started with bar soap and
and ventured into a little bit of liquid
soap but found out my love is cream soap
and that is what i applied for the grant
for
i made cream soap and i had a failure
where it separated and at that point i
wanted i didn't know what caused the
failure and so part of this grant was to
figure out how
to
to reduce my risk of that happening
happening again
so the grant is for
creating sound
or good manufacturing practices
they're not any rules they're legislated
to us they're just some manufacturing
practices that a um
a manufacturer will follow and that
allows the customer to feel comfortable
that they're getting a good and
consistent product every time
so the cream soaps is different from bar
soaps and it's different from liquid
soaps it's kind of a combination that it
uses lye that each of them uses but what
it does is it adds a super cream and
my these cream soaps will be in a
jar instead of a bar or instead of a
pump
and
the the
cream soaps have a lather that just
i compare the lather to somewhere
between like a pudding and whipped cream
it is just this wonderful luscious
lather it's not real bubbly it's creamy
and it's just
it makes you feel good during the whole
experience of using it and it just is
fabulous
i in the past i've done some what they
call product testing at the at the point
of manufacturing which basically says
that at the point that i was done making
the product that it was free from
bacteria
this grant is going to allow me to do
challenge product challenge testing and
that
basically says
you've added a preservative is that
preservative the right preservative is
it going to do its job and so it will
actually they will
try and make the product fail
by adding different
bacterias or whatever to it and that
product testing is five hundred dollars
a piece and so that was just a huge
thing in order to do as much product
challenge testing as i wanted to do that
it'll help with that
you